on va donc s'intéresser à l'amour est
dans le pré dans l'épisode d'hier on a
pu assister aux premiers instants à la
ferme des prétendants de l'eau des
prétendantes de laurent d'élire un
moment qui a très vite tourné au malaise
pour les deux femmes puisque
l'agriculteur n'a pas arrêté de faire
des allusions sexuelles
il s'est lâché hull en voilà il a fait
des petits dribbles et regarder ceci est
préparée par jeanne mizrahi non pas
celui-là démarre très mal la nouvelle
[Rires]
maman moi j'entendais dans mon lien et
musique et dans mon lit par contre de la
lecture t'es pas obligé de te jeter
dessus car il arrive
c'est à libon 20 mais c'est tellement
lourd il a quand même été sympathique
moteur mais c'est trop il a été surnommé
sur les réseaux sociaux le beauf d'or
aux menaces mais si on a on lui a dit
36,15 malaise ya eu que des commentaires
négatifs c'est trop il fait un concours
de t-shirt mouillé je les aime bien mais
non c'est sale uriné dans un buisson là
les bords de seine moi aussi jury des
données non les autres y avait des
approches à timoré timide et lui c'est
beaucoup trop c'est dur mais les sur son
tracteur et tous les cas d'un casting
c'est d'avoir plusieurs personnalités
oui c'est sa personnalité
moi je pense que le plus important c'est
de savoir si c'est les scènes mama la
salle et jeanne ou pas et ça n'a pas
l'air de les gêner et puis on à jean
michel maire c'est pareil pour nous je
veux dire sûr que non jean-michel il est
extrêmement confiant libre oui alors je
défendrai toujours merci je pense que la
prod pousse dans ce dans ce style là
évidemment la scénariste ou ça ait ourir
s'est lui qualifié sur la chose mais
c'est normal c'est moi il a raison
michel la télé virgin mais bon quel nom
il a raison jean-michel non c'est pour
lagacé passe comme si m6 donc sous les
eaux ce que l'amour est peut être se
respecte mamie un regard délavé la vague
à 300k la croissance dont d'âge mais la
question c'est est ce qu'il joue un rôle
ou alors il est lui-même visiblement il
est lui-même simplement lancé de la
télévision donc on peut on sérieusement
mon appui sur les sur les
caractéristiques des âmes la télé c'est
la commedia dell'arte donc il faut
appuyer le trait il faut grosse il a
peut-être juste envie de faire l'amour
c'est pas de l'amour est dans le pré
l'ipod qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent et
ballon
après si vous ne connaissez pas un petit
peu grosse lorsqu'il a été castée pour
ça et évidemment de la demande et de
grossir le trait et des tracés à 6 ans
et lourdaud évidemment il a pas mais
kaba soir par hasard et ça résume bien
ce programme c'est vraiment n'importe
vous savez comment c'est triste c'est
incroyable ce que tu n'aimes pas grave
je leur avais bien quand même
tu as le droit de pas les mêmes et à
peine moins de déminer ou là les années
quand c'est mieux comme ça
il a des petits yeux comme ça alors on
va regarder a donné un extrait pour
marquer quelques points auprès de ses
prétendantes lors on leur a proposé
d'aller se baigner dans un jacuzzi
non mais quand on a vu la tête du
jacuzzi regardez il ya eu une mini raz
sera notre jacuzzi la suite à un coup de
coude sur les chaussures
[Musique]
[Rires]
ah ça fait du bien du coup on fait
monter avec eux en fait mission en fait
le bal masqué où vais je vous ai pas dit
mr better dimanche je suis balma ce
qu'ils pensent qu'on est les premières
de l'amour est donc clair a fait
trempette obama nous a pas parlé
arriva wimax et ça c'est un dans la
campagne
ouais tu te sens des chaussettes mais me
baigner dans des lacs à rabat
bien entendu thalasso pas cher mais y
compris s'arroser après exactement comme
il l'a fait vraiment bonne et j'ai
jamais eu ton avis sur l'amour est dans
le pré tout est ce que c'est une
émission tu regarde pas mais je
regardais au début et paprec a débordé
salué des conneries pareilles je ferai
ça ça te plait plus là mais moi je
critique pas je regarde pas et voilà oui
mais ça ne s'appelle plus et a vanté
bien maintenant sept points de vue sur
ce qui est naturel alors moyens c'est ça
un peu là maintenant mais je critique
pas moi je m'emballe
[Rires]
mais qu'est ce que je suis le mec ça me
plaît pas je regarde pas et je ne
critique pas qu'est ce qui te dérange
pas critiqué puisqu'il dérange c'est que
c'est trop scénarisé nord oui voilà
c'est ça c'est trop isabelle jean michel
merle dit que c'est vrai mais c'est vrai
mais bon accueil à michel mr et à dire
là aujourd'hui je ratais ya butin nommé
à papa n'est venu la jeanne de la rédac
moi je suis pas loin de cette émission
mais je suis d'accord qu'il ya vraiment
des personnages qu'on l'air lourd mais
je pense aussi que c'est scénarisé
d'accord voilà donc vous êtes tout
personne n'est d'accord et qu'ils
appellent ici maintenant la table ça
fait du mal pour isa menottes chirac il
est emmené un autre agriculteur qui
recherchent l'amour a emmené ses
prétendants de faire ses courses
une sortie qui s'est avérée encore très
coquine série c voilà c'est ce que je
leur reproche qui est fait actuellement
c'est que c'est un petit peu un petit
peu plus voilà c'est vrai j'ai faim j'ai
francs
mais il va falloir le corriger celui là
où je suis ici parce que manger ces
nouveaux jacques
[Musique]
c'est
je pensais d'eux et mais ce qui est dur
l'un portait sur un court
non non et non
en tout cas vous voyez bien dans cet
extrait que c'est ce que je disais tout
à l'heure elle aime ça ça les fait rire
aussi seller et un sur six est partagé
le problème ce serait si elle était
gênée elle se sentait un peu au fisc et
même pas du tout donc je vois pas où est
le problème
le gros problème de cette émission c'est
quand ça vient de karine et c'est pas
son rôle le marchand par mais il se
passer au pakistan mais qui n'a pas fait
pareil avait déjà bien l'allusion à
rigoler voilà c'est comme ça après c'est
vrai peut-être que la production
maintenant appuyé un peu dessus parce
qu'on perd un peu l'essence même je
trouve de l'amour est dans le pré c'est
plus du dating en bottes maintenant mais
c'est que ça je trouve mais bon on a
tous fait pareil l'essor de la courbe de
trucs que tu fais des cours tu ne parles
quéquette toi ne t'énerve mais pas
content personne n'a compris ce qu'il a
dit mais quand tu vois que c'est court
pour ne pas recruter quelqu'un alors
qu'en fait ils marchent pas mal cette
année vont soumettre les scores qu'ils
faisaient a beaucoup baissé mais ça se
maintient à un niveau correct ce qui est
évident ce qui est scénarisé c'est que
ils sont suivis toute la journée pas de
caméra c'est sûr et il garde que ça
d'aussi garde que ça c'est qu'axa que
les intéressés qu'ils veulent mais axé
là-dessus en deux heures et garder ton
super mais ils sont
[Rires]
fedict loi sur un peu près une heure au
supermarché ils ont gardé que deux
minutes il parle de saucisson de courge
cetera ils ont pas gardé le reste ben
voilà salaire il avec susan va lui
répondre
toutefois je professionnel c'est
celui-là ça ça c'est ça c'est un message
fort
[Applaudissements]